fox news contributor lisa booth joins us
now to react lisa what do you make of
this isn't it just
it's just unbelievable these scenes and
also the reaction or the lack of a
reaction from those people who lectured
us endlessly about police brutality
well in the ironies i think the left
they're okay they want police states
they want authoritarianism as long as
they're the ones
that are in charge and that's the
scariest thing and that's the scariest
thing about coven steve over the past
couple of years
is witnessing how susceptible free
nations are to tyranny i mean you have
trudeau trudeau treating these truckers
treating these canadians as if they're
terrorists and why because they hold
quote unquote unacceptable views for ron
wrong think i mean look at what they
want all they want is bodily autonomy
they want the right to say no to
vaccines that are experimental and
ineffective
but but that's their crime is wrong
think and then instead see how trudeau
has treated them he has invoked the
emergencies act he has turned canada
into a police state he has had people
arrested he has frozen bank accounts and
he's not alone in this mentality either
i mean look at what's happening in the
united states you have the biden
administration tried to label parents
standing up for their kids at school
boards as domestic terrorists and try to
weaponize the doj against them so this
march towards authoritarianism both here
in the united states and abroad is real
and and people need to wake up to it i
totally agree by the way i mean i
wouldn't say that the vaccines are
ineffective i'd say that they're
effective at protecting you but not
anywhere else so there's absolutely no
case for these mandates they're
completely unjustified on any scientific
grounds and you're exactly right that
they love this excuse to push this
control and the fact that it's
you know it it's directed at the exact
same people who at the beginning of all
this oh we have to sort of you know like
really make sure that we recognize the
heroism of the essential workers
whatever when the essential workers turn
around and disobey the dictats of the
technocrats and the politicians suddenly
they're the enemy
well and the reason i said that is
because we were originally told they
would stop transmission that's not
happened and allegedly that's absolutely
right multiple multiple shots to you
know to to prevent is what they're
saying so that's why i called them that
but to your point steve i mean look at
the mentality of the left look at
something that the governor of
connecticut
recently said in lifting some mandates
he said you have earned your freedom
that's what he he thinks he's the
liberator when he's the oppressor i miss
this on the left are the oppressors he
said you have earned your freedom that's
what he said steve but what he doesn't
understand is our liberty is god-given
it's not government given the
constitution protects our god-given
liberty from the government we were born
free we don't need the governor of
connecticut to give us that liberty and
so what i hope that americans take from
what we have seen throughout covet is
looking at the government and deciding
what role we want the government to have
in our lives i mean you look at the way
the left has abused their power what
have they done they've used covet to get
more power to amass more power to take
to force vaccines on people to force
mask mandates on people and then you
look at what governor ron desantis has
done in florida
he has kept it free he has gotten the
government out of the way he has
respected individual liberty that's the
difference between the two political
parties and so i i hope people take that
mentality they are clear-eyed and
heading to the midterms uh this november
because
we're in the fight of our lives for
freedom and for liberty totally agreed
that's what i keep trying to remind
people you know it was democrats who
masked our kids it was democrats who
closed our schools it was democrats who
shut down local businesses all of it
unjustified none of it made a difference
you just look at the data the comparison
between florida and somewhere like
california with the extreme corona
shutdowns there's no justification for
it it was all about their power control
wanted to be the center of attention
they should be held accountable we
totally will focus on that um lisa great
to see hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else